joe biden talks tough on vladimir putin
in his state of the union address the
u.s president warning the russian leader
has no idea what's coming
but beyond threats and sanctions what
can the u.s do to stop russia's actions
on ukraine this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
hasam seeker it is traditionally the
most widely viewed speech in american
president mace the annual state of the
union address to a joint session of
congress laying down the president's
plans for the coming year but events
overseas often overshadow those plans
and force a rethink and in this address
biden's first as president the conflict
unfolding in ukraine featured heavily in
its opening minutes it was a recognition
that the u.s president was speaking to
the world this time and not just the
american people joe biden added the
united states the long list of countries
barring their airspace to russian planes
he went after vladimir putin over
russia's attack on ukraine framing the
debate as a battle between democracy and
autocracy
russia's vladimir putin sought to shake
the very foundations of the free world
thinking he could make it bend
to his menacing ways
but he badly miscalculated
he thought he could roll into ukraine
and the world would roll over
instead he met with a mall a wall of
strength he never anticipated or
imagined he met the ukrainian people
the united states
department of justice is assembling a
dedicated task force to go after the
crimes of the russian oligarchs
we're joining with european allies to
find and seize their yachts their luxury
apartments their private jets
we're coming for you or ill-begotten
gains and tonight
i'm announcing that we will join our
allies in closing off american air space
to all russian flights further isolating
russia and adding additional squeeze on
their economy
our russian foreign minister sergey
lavrov has been reacting to the western
response to his country's invasion of
its neighbor
speaking to al jazeera lavrov said
moscow would not let ukraine obtain
nuclear weapons and he warned if a third
world war took place it would be nuclear
and destructive lavrov says russia would
face real danger if kiev acquired
nuclear warheads
in ukraine fighting has intensified in
and around the crimean peninsula that
russia annexed in 2014. northeast in the
city of hurston russian troops and tanks
are reportedly in control of the city
center and ukrainian soldiers say
they've been surrounded in the port city
of mariupol northwest of crimea
reports also suggest russian forces have
installed checkpoints around the
peninsula the ukrainian government has
dismissed some of those reports as
propaganda
[Music]
so let's talk about all of this now with
our guests in michigan i'm joined by
aaron cool director of debate at the
university of michigan he's also editor
and co-author of the state of the union
is memorable addresses of the last 60
years
in kiev is kira rudik a ukrainian member
of parliaments and joining us from
washington robert hunter former u.s
ambassador to nato warm welcome to all
of you so uh
aaron let me start with you then what
did you make of of the president's
speech and and what he had said about um
ukraine was was it enough
i think it was probably a little less
than than some were expecting um you
know it's only an hour's speech and so
and he's has a lot of things to talk
about including domestic issues like the
economy inflation in kovid it ended up
being about the first 10 minutes of the
speech about 15 percent
but in some ways it was the the zenith
of the speech because there was a lot of
bipartisan support for the position a
lot of positive imagery you know those
with the colors of ukraine uh the
ambassador uh was there and um you know
directly uh talk about but
um i think it's it's a very tough
position for him to be in i look back to
you know jimmy carter's state of the
union address in 1980 after the soviet
union invasion of afghanistan and um he
kind of went back to that invasion at
several points in in the speech but
president biden chose to just talk at it
to talk about it at the top for 10
minutes and that's it's good because
that's the time that most of the people
are tuned in and it's the height um but
i think there was some expectation
before that even more time would be
devoted given the significance of the
issue and how it's dominating the
domestic international media scene
kiera rudick uh joining us from uh kiev
and we appreciate you joining us from
the ukrainian capital and we hope you're
staying safe there um what did you take
from the american president's speech
was was it enough for you
there is one key point that all
ukrainians are waiting for
is if our allies are going to
uh
the close the sky for us or not this is
the main thing this is what we are
really looking forward to
we don't really care if it will be
official or unofficial if it will be
along with the rules of nato or it will
be
the way that russia is doing it saying
it was not us
every single day ukrainian cities are
being bombarded by russian missiles
every single day when we are talking and
discussing and negotiating and thinking
what else can be done ukrainian people
are telling what can be done we need a
no-fly zone over ukraine or at least
some of ukrainian cities because every
single day the only matter for us to
lose the only one
is that if putin will be able to polish
ukrainian soil by from the sky we are
doing very well on the land side we we
definitely will be able to push back and
we definitely will be able to win but
before uh that there is a high chance
that putin will destroy all our cities
and destroy our infrastructure the way
that will be thrown back uh to 20 30
years uh behind and this is is so
frustrating right now i'm thankful to
the u.s president for all the support on
all the sanctions and all the direction
that he have given uh the world
community on how to help ukraine however
what we are expecting right now is uh by
any means help us to protect us from the
skies for the last seven days of war
we have experienced maybe 20 times when
there were missile attacks on uh on tf
and you have seen the destruction that
have happened and you have seen that
right now putin is using forbidden
weaponry and he even is not uh
hiding it so given all of that uh we
have the country that are obeying the
rules and saying okay we will figure it
out give us some time and we have a
tyrant who is trying to destroy ukraine
with no rules with no rules of war with
no rules of
war crimes with no rules of using
weapons and the world is watching and
saying we will help you out guys just
hold on so we are holding on we are
pushing back but oh what if we fail and
i'm so concerned given what we have seen
in kharkim given what we have seen
around kiev that we may fail not because
we did wrong not because we didn't fight
enough not because we didn't have enough
soldiers not because we weren't brave
enough not because we didn't have enough
weaponry but just because from the sky
from the air side we didn't have the
protection that we need so badly right
now so i'm asking every single uh
government in every single country to
try and find a way to support ukraine
and provide it with no-fly zone right
now over obviously our cities this is
where we ask you from the bottom of our
hearts protect us we are in the same
side on the same side in this battle
it's not between russia and ukraine it's
not between
the countries right now it's in between
the civilizations and we are here
kira you talk a lot about the the
no-flying zone there and i know many
that is something that many ukrainians
have been calling uh for and we'll we'll
get to that in a moment but i want to
ask robert hunter uh what you took from
this speech and and did it leave you
with with questions about uh where
america goes next
well it's interesting the reference to
the jimmy carter speech in
1980 after the uh
uh russian invasion of uh afghanistan
because i wrote that speech for jimmy
carter and it does bring back haunting
memories uh mr biden last night
did a couple of things number one he was
not going to go negotiate on television
and negotiations are what are going to
have to happen at this point uh china
apparently has made an offer and what we
will say
but mr biden secondly ruled out any u.s
direct military involvement and uh that
involves a no-fly zone uh the united
states does not prepare to get involved
uh ukraine is uh not a uh a nato member
even though
uh it did say and has said for 14 years
that the ukraine will join nato which
creates a moral responsibility uh if
nothing else
uh he also however
tried to demonstrate the support
not just of the united states morally
and politically
on this as a guest from michigan said
the bipartisan support
but also to emphasize that mr putin is
totally isolated in the outside world
it has been i think quite successful
effort
with all of the allies a lot of other
countries
to get
the most intense sanctions that have
ever been imposed but
one has to be realistic and
despite uh all the fact that what the
member of parliament says
what the
courage of the ukrainian people are
sanctions i don't think are going to
work certainly not in the short term
unless for some reason mr putin decides
he wants to stop or there's something
he wants that can legitimately be worked
out with russia
i'm afraid this is going to become a lot
worse
and the united states says mr biden made
clear last night it's
going to provide money and weapons uh
but it is not going to get engaged in
the war in any way well let's talk a bit
more about the possibility of a no-fly
zone aaron core if if nato
were to enforce a no-fly zone over
ukraine as many ukraines are asking for
is that a viable option at this point
and if not why
right i mean not not from my perspective
kind of you know giving the read of what
it looks like politically there have
been you know interviews i saw this
interview with florida senator marco
rubio um and just said he thought that
if if that happened you know that it
could cause trigger world war three um
you know because once that occurs you're
they're you know guaranteed to be
conflict and that escalates the united
states involvement and culpability in
the conflict and
and you know the where the endpoint is
um you know nobody would know and
as the ambassador said um you know
i think that president biden was very
clear
in his speech um that there's not going
to be uh us military involvement
directly and i think that would include
the no fly zone so just like some of his
comments about about sanction and
military and financial other support
banning russian planes from united
states airspace going after you know
oligarchs and and ill-gotten gains and
things like that with the justice
department while all those things
receive bipartisan support um the exact
converse is true of when talking about a
no-fly zone there doesn't seem to be any
domestic political support on either
side of the aisle and including the
president
of this no-fly zone because of the
potential for uh escalation in that
conflict so that doesn't seem likely
absent some major change
in the situation
well let's let's put that to keira
rudick then uh you talked earlier about
the need for a no-fly zone but the
concern that nato has over that
is that it would escalate this war uh to
a level uh that it doesn't to somewhere
that it doesn't want to go because it
would mean um
fighting uh the russian military
directly um and that could escalate into
a much wider war would could which could
be um which could be worse not just for
ukrainians but for for many more people
in europe what do you say to that
so
first of all i totally understand that
because i'm a politician myself
and uh but i'm also sure that if there
are rules that uh exist and we are
talking about the rules that uh
the nato members only have to protect
nato members
um
there are ways to
go over those rules and afghanistan was
not a nato member and syria was not a
nato member right
and right now we are talking about a
european country that needs support and
i'm sure and i have been talking to
different generals from different
european countries and this is right now
one of the ways that everybody is
discussing the the way
that will allow poli that will allow not
to get into the uh bigger conflict
politically but that will provide us
with the enough to support from the air
this is basically the goal this is
basically the task i don't see it as the
one being impossible especially that we
have seen putin who for eight years was
declining that his uh uh that his army
is on our territory and this his army is
in ukrainian donbass
so
uh with uh
there could be a document put together
and i know that some us officials are
working on it right now that would say
with certain limitations and with
certain items and only for the
protection purposes here and there we
can help and support uh for these
particular reasons
and i'm sure
and i'm super super uh convinced that at
some point it will get to that
my issue is that we see that all the
steps that the democratic countries are
taking
they are like two weeks later and then
then putin's actions and we as
ukrainians are paying
for it with our lives and with our blood
because the sanctions were in which we
are super grateful for i won't be super
honest we are very grateful for them
sanctions was put on friday so uh the
first day when the russians started
feeling it was monday so the three days
we had to die
to and fight and the because because it
was just like the time issue so if
everybody in their hearts will agree
that the protection will will be
implemented then we need to make sure
that it will be
implemented as fast as possible if we in
our hearts do not agree that it will
happen then i want to be very open with
everybody and i am very open with it
that there is a chance that ukraine may
fail we are will be fighting as hell we
will be uh protecting our country but at
some point given what is happening right
now we may not be able to
and then there will be a question for
everybody about like what are we going
to do with the country that is occupied
by russia uh in the center of europe and
if the solution to protect the country
while we are independent and fighting
was better than having another country
all right let's hop it marianne let's
put some of that let's put some of that
to uh
let's put some of that to to robert
hunter then uh wha what happens if uh
all of these measures that uh the united
states and its allies uh have taken
don't make any difference and fail to
force putin into retreat and ukraine is
essentially
an occupied
country and
you know dare i ask if if if he keeps
going beyond that determined to
re-establish this kind of sphere of
influence that the old soviet union's
leaders gave up uh disastrously in in in
vladimir putin's view what happens then
well first i think
the russians are calculating that
they're prepared to take more risks
in order to subjugate and that's the
word we're talking about ukraine then
the united states in particular as the
leader of the of the
nato alliance is prepared to run
and that uh game of uh threatened
escalation uh mr putin has already
demonstrated that he is uh he has
succeeded at that
and the united states and the other nato
allies have said it is not worth risking
escalation maybe even to the nuclear
level for ukraine uh that unfortunately
is a fact a harsh reality
if indeed mr putin decides to move
forward to occupy all of ukraine and in
the short term sanctions
aren't gonna work uh sanctions will
isolate and maybe even destroy the
russian economy over years but it's not
gonna work right now but if that happens
uh then uh we'll see what mr putin's
prepared to do i believe there is
already a tacit understanding and this
is a harsh reality
that mr putin's going to be able to get
away with whatever he wants to do in
ukraine at pain and suffering of the
ukrainian people who are being
extraordinarily brave but
quite frankly the only reason i suspect
that mr putin hasn't already
gone throughout the country is that at
least in the pain of russians being
killed
east and inadequacy russian forces but
the tacit understanding is
yes and i'm going to say this is the way
it would sound to a
an outside observer yes you can have
ukraine that's too bad but you're not
going to be allowed to touch any of the
nato allies at least with open
aggression and i think mr putin
understands that and is prepared to
respect it because uh mr mr biden has
been very clear and this he can't back
down from if there was open aggression
against any nato ally the united states
would have to respond or nato is
finished and america's european power is
finished and i think putin
understands that but
ukraine
i won't say being sacrificed but uh i'm
afraid unless mr putin decides to stop
at some point ukraine is going to suffer
a lot more and will be
um all right
aaron corey what's your what's your take
on that that um
as terrible uh a toll as this is taking
on ukraine uh the us and and its allies
would not be prepared to go any further
than what they're doing now the much
beyond what they're doing now
yeah i mean there's you know some other
things that have been discussed that are
short of the no-fly zone i mean uh
senator joe manchin
has called for a ban on on russian oil
exports there's talk about taking action
against russia inside of the united
nations security council i mean some of
the proposals were just you know debuted
last night about the the banning of
russian planes and airspace and and
embolding emboldening the department of
justice to go after oligarchs and that's
that stuff is tough i mean they're um
you know the wealth is is intertwined in
a lot of different areas
such as you know real estate
professional sports groups and things
like that so so yes it's just it's a
very timely thing and people are talking
about we're just you know one week into
this but people are already talking
about you know something that lasting
months or years and so and so yes i mean
eventually if
um if president putin goes too far or um
you know troops from nato uh or uh
people from
nato and other countries kind of become
involved then that may tie the united
states hands but um we certainly don't
know the future and this just may be the
beginning but yes in the in the short
term just the the daily um you know
suffering um the horrendous actions
occurring is likely to occur and that'll
drive the policies things we think about
right now that may not be possible um
it's just it's unclear be given the how
things um escalate and and what kind of
the appetite of both the american public
and and the world
that's watching this and the media
landscape is and and nobody knows the
answer to that as of now
uh keira riddick i'm probably going to
give you what's probably going to be the
last word on this uh to you and i want
to ask you as well should the west have
seen this coming
oh i have a comment about it
um
about that yeah well that will happen i
will have to suffer
uh the point is
we and this we do have definitely do
understand what's going on right now
like in the world politics and uh how
ukraine is as a country
we are receiving support from one side
but we know that the most of the work
will have to do ourselves there is no
doubt to that but again
when you are calculating and waiting the
risks the issue would be like what would
happen if
there will be a
russia-controlled country large country
with huge potential and gas pipes and
and
chernobyl on its territory in the center
of ukraine
and
it will be and instead of having the
country that is fighting for its freedom
fighting for european union it will be a
country who will be like producing
additional russian soldiers
are we sure that this is like the world
wants because if so
like it's it's easy and quickly to go to
that
then second thing is should the west
think he's coming well putin was very
very very adamant about what he's going
to do
and it started i think i was in the
united states for
in
early november when this information was
shared that he is going to attack
and
since that time so it was not used since
that time ukraine has been at the
uh pre-war situation and uh
everybody was uh expecting this because
there we had we all had intelligence we
all had the information that he is
gathering the troops we had high hope
that he wouldn't attack but
the understanding was there a week
before war i was at the munich security
conference and there i was talking to
members of for
different governments and uh
with
the military representatives etc and
everybody was saying yeah we think it's
the chance is less than 10
and my reply to that was okay if the
chance is less than ten percent uh if
you have the list of sanctions please
show them to him right now so he would
know what he's playing against
and for for various reasons it didn't
happen so i think we all were too
optimistic about what he is going or not
going to do i think that was a mistake
from from the overall democratic
idea of
yeah he will think about citizen that
you're going to be getting killed etc
as a person as a political leader here
in ukraine who has been uh at war with
putin for eight years i can tell you
he's crazy he's unpredictable and we
should not anticipate logical decisions
on his side
keep it in mind on that note we're going
to have to leave it there we're out of
time uh thank you to all three of you uh
um aaron core in michigan kia rudik in
kiev and robert hunter in washington
thanks very much for being on inside
story and thank you as always for
watching you can see this program again
anytime just go to our website
aljazeera.com for further discussion go
to our facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle there it's at aj inside story
for me has them seeker and the whole
team here in daha bye for now
[Music]
you